- So...
(audience clapping)
On tour, you saw me,
or they're right here.
They're In-Ears.
We call them In-Ears.
But you can decorate them.
- Ah-ha.
- And I go gold, sparkly, seventies.
- [Olivia] Cute.
- But you have photos on yours.
I didn't know you could do photos.
- (gasps) Yeah, you can put photos.
- No one told me this.
- Yeah, you put photos of your
kids, put photos of anyone.
Those are mine.
(audience cheering)
- Edward Cullen.
- Edward.
That's my baby.
Like, that's my thing, yeah.
- I'm a "Twilight" nerd.
- That's Edward Cullen on my In-Ears.
- Yes, yes.
(audience cheering)
And a nice purple lavender.
I like that, too.
- Yeah, he's my guiding light on tour.
You know, just to have to have
my lucky charm.
- As he should be, yeah.
- Yeah, love him.
- What's on your In-Ears now?
- My In-Ears now for this "Guts" tour...
I'm gonna get a new face every tour,
so taking suggestions
for the next one.
- Okay.
- Maybe I'll put you on my next one.
(audience cheering)
- Aim for like something random.
- (laughing) Yeah.
- Like Betty White.
- (claps) Yeah!
- Like, just something random, right?
That makes you happy.
- Yeah, but this year it's...
- Totally.
- Oh, it's Kim Cattrall!
- Yeah, it's Kim Cattrall.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Kelly] I love that.
- It's Kim Cattrall
from "Sex and the City."
Samantha from "Sex and the City."
She's my favorite.
And she's, like, drinking
a little martini,
and I thought it was great.
- Why not?
- You know what that says?
"Celebrate."
- Yeah.
- Every time you put your In-Ears in.
I like it.
- Uh-huh.
- I think I did know you could do photos.
Do you have Rue?
Do you have Rue on yours?
Oh, okay.
Her dog.
I was like,
"Maybe I have seen photos."
- Oh, cute.
- [Kelly] I know, I need to be cooler.
I'm gonna aim higher.
- Next time.